to our coronavirus coverage now demand
for covid testing has spiked all across
the valley several new sites are
available and some original spots have
relocated to meet demand that includes
unlv site now moving to san boyd stadium
madison kimbrough is at that new site
and shares how things are going madison
does testing officially start what time
yeah so it starts at 5 30 and will last
until 10 30. take a look behind me as
you can see there is a lot going on the
southern nevada health district is
offering free testing for those who
drive up and as you can see the line is
massive they're also administering
vaccines too we arrived at the area of
broadbent and russell road to hundreds
and hundreds of cars in line around 3 30
this afternoon testing here at unlv sam
boyd stadium has taken the place of
their paradise campus location one of
the biggest reasons being this new
location will provide more space for
cars and people to get through
less concerns about traffic for those
driving on the roadways some people are
just now getting in line we spoke to one
woman who has been here for hours
he actually got here about 10 minutes
after one
so
yeah we've been here for a very long
time actually i was gonna come around
three o'clock but then i decided no i
better go a little bit earlier just in
case so i'm glad i did i was very glad
to hear that they had moved the testing
site over here to this location
there will be 300 covid 19 vaccines and
1200 tests each night on a first come
first serve basis depending on daily
supplies and staffing tests are
self-swap pcr tests and results take
about 72 hours to process now again take
a look at everything that's going on
right now a lot of cars and it's looking
like they're just letting people in
right now as we speak while it is first
come first served the health district
encourages
to register online ahead of time and
create an account which will in turn
make this process go a lot easier if
you sasha reporting live madison
kimbrough here at sam boyd stadium live
local now